FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, everyone.
I'm Felipe Hoffa.
I'm a Google Cloud Platform
Developer Advocate.
And today I'm at
the GitHub offices
to learn about how they
are using the BigQuery.
You might already know
that BigQuery's great
when you went to analyze
terabytes of data in seconds.
And that there are
a lot of open data
sets around that you can
query whenever you want.
But BigQuery is not
only good for open data,
a lot of corporations,
enterprises,
companies are using
BigQuery to understand
their own data, their users,
their own metrics, et cetera.
And today at GitHub I'm
going to look at both worlds.
Because we have a lot
of, at least three open
datasets about
GitHub that they're
using to understand
their own company.
So today, Alyson La, from the
data science team at GitHub
will join me.
We will explore how they are
using BigQuery and other tools
and open data to understand
their organization.
So Alyson, thank you so
much for inviting me.
ALYSON LA: Yeah,
thanks for being here.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes I know
you've done great stuff here
at GitHub, and before
we get started,
I wanted to mention
to everyone how
you've been doing awesome stuff
like, I went to the GitHub
Universe Conference.
You published these
GitHub Octoverse.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
you were behind it.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so I was part
of a cross-departmental team
that helped publish this
infographic, if you will,
all about the state
of the Octoverse.
And it has a few
different sections,
but one of the sections
is focused on open source.
And it was really
important to me
to be able to publish those
open source metrics using
the open data set,
and be able to publish
the queries behind it for
the community to reuse.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice, so you
have that Octoverse here
and a lot of different
open source analysis.
But before we get
to how you made it,
I would love to know how you
got started in this world.
ALYSON LA: Absolutely.
So I got started about
four years ago, I
was one of the first
accountants at GitHub actually.
And when I started, I had
never seen a terminal before
or seen code at all.
But I was really curious.
So I asked a lot of
questions to my coworkers
and started going to meet-ups.
And eventually I got to learn
how to code a little bit.
And using my analysis
skills as an accountant
in Excel and hacking
skills that I
learned from going to
all these meet-ups,
I was able to parlay that into
a position on our data science
team as an analyst.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice, so you
start as an accountant,
you started going
to meet-ups like--
ALYSON LA: So, all around the
Bay Area there's meet-ups,
for example, Women Who Code.
And there's RailsBridge on
the weekends and Rails Girls
meet-ups where I was
able to make some apps.
And then also by searching
GitHub and seeing projects,
I was able to fork them
and clone them and learn
how to hack that way.
FELIPE HOFFA: So working
within a company,
you were able to find
open datasets about GitHub
and that turned you into a
data person, data analyst.
That is really cool.
What kind of open datasets
do you have available?
ALYSON LA: So the open datasets
that I've used on BigQuery,
there's a few different ones.
So first thing there's
the GitHub archive,
which is all of the event data.
So every single time someone
stars or pushes or creates
a issue comment
or a pull request,
that's recorded as an event.
And so that's one dataset.
It's called the GitHub archive.
FELIPE HOFFA: Started by
Ilya Grigorik some years ago.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
A Googler.
And then another dataset is
the GitHub public dataset
that you helped publish.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, we
recently released that one.
ALYSON LA: Yeah,
that's a great one.
It's all the contents of
all of the repositories.
And that one's different
from the events data,
it's only repositories that
have a detectable open source
license.
FELIPE HOFFA: So for
open source projects
that we know to
be open source, we
are taking them and
putting them on BigQuery.
All of the content, the code.
So I've been able
to run analysis
like, hey, do we have more
[INAUDIBLE] or the spaces.
What is more public?
That's been really cool.
And we are now having a
third dataset-- GHTorrent.
That's a different project.
It does pretty nice job
of making all of the data,
like you have archive,
we have all the events.
But with GHTorrent we're
able to see everything.
Like different
tables, normalized,
to see, for example, where
are people come from?
What countries do
they come from?
ALYSON LA: Yeah,
so the GHTorrent
includes the geographic data.
And all of the datasets
are really complementary,
so it's really nice that they're
all in one place on BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: If anyone
can come to BigQuery,
we find these datasets, start
doing jobs between them.
Just to show everyone what
kind of queries you run,
can you show a little bit of
how you work with BigQuery?
Your tools?
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so we
can start by looking
at the Octoverse and the queries
that powered the open source
section.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
ALYSON LA: So here's
the Octoverse.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
ALYSON LA: So for example,
this graph was pretty popular.
Of the 15 most popular languages
on GitHub by open port request.
And the percent change
from the previous period.
I published the queries
that go along with this.
So here's the example of
the most popular languages
by port quest using JSON
extract of the events payload.
FELIPE HOFFA: So that's
an important element.
On the GitHub archive
dataset we have
a lot of data encoded as JSON.
ALYSON LA: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we can do
that with unstructured data.
We can store JSON.
So we don't have to
think about columns
when we're storing data.
And now you need
to write queries
like this, that
extract data from JSON.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: It seems
pretty easy to do.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
So just by using
the JSON extract
and then using a time stamp
and choosing the date range.
And this was a
12-month date range,
was able to get this output
of say the top 25 languages.
And then changing the
date range to compare it
against the previous
time period.
FELIPE HOFFA: As you
publish these queries,
anyone can come to GitHub
take these queries,
copy them into the
query and start
running their own analysis.
ALYSON LA: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: Starting
with your queries.
ALYSON LA: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: So OK, we
have to these queries.
They're exposed.
And these queries run
actually inside the query.
The Web UI.
What can you tell
me about the Web UI?
How do you use it?
ALYSON LA: Oh, yes.
So going to the Google
BigQuery, there's
a couple of different
places where you
can see the different datasets.
So here is the GitHub
archive dataset
and it has these different
table structures.
And then the BigQuery
public dataset is here
and under GitHub
repos is where you
can find all of the tables that
are the repositories that we
talked about the file contents.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, so
here you have repos that
have in the contents table.
That's a huge table.
And if you click on it.
I think it has more if
you click on the Details.
Yeah, it has 1.7, 1.9
terabytes of data now.
1.7.
And then on GitHub archive
we have all of the events.
And we have them organized
by day, month, year.
The query you were using?
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so if
we go back to this gist,
you can just copy and paste this
into the UI here on BigQuery.
And it'll know to pull up
the CAB archive day table.
So we can run that query.
FELIPE HOFFA: I see you're
running everything between,
looking between 2015.
ALYSON LA: So one year.
FELIPE HOFFA: One year of data.
By day, And this query
goes over a lot of days.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
And especially with the
extract of the payload
to pull out the
repo base language.
And also, we're doing an
extract of the JSON payload
to make sure that it's only
the action equals open.
So it's only counting
the pull request once
by when they're opened.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And here we already found what
were the most popular languages
last year.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, for
this date range then,
we have the output
of the language name
and the count of the total
pull requests by language.
FELIPE HOFFA: So a
reminder for everyone
that wants to play
with this data, here
we looked at the
full year of data,
but BigQuery, we give you a
free terabyte of query to run
your queries every month.
Now if you want to make
those queries, [INAUDIBLE]
last longer, you're still
waiting the full year
when you're playing,
go for a few days,
and then just go
over the full year.
ALYSON LA: Exactly, so when
doing exploratory analysis,
I usually limit it to maybe
seven days or two weeks.
And then when I'm ready to
look over the full date range
that I want to
analyze, then I'll
open it up to the
full date range.
FELIPE HOFFA:
That's pretty cool.
We analyze about, how
many gigabytes of data?
ALYSON LA: 600.
FELIPE HOFFA: 600 gigabytes
of data in 20 seconds,
parsing JSON in the meantime.
That's pretty cool.
ALYSON LA: Well, yeah.
That's a great tool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then,
you were able to take
this laptop, these queries
and visualize them.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
That was a visual designer
that all of the pretty
visualizations in Octoverse.
But I've done
visualizations separately
in other side projects using
the GitHub archive public
dataset in Tableau.
And then also, more
recently, I'm using Looker.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
Can we take a look on
how you use Tableau
and then we can jump to what
we're doing with Looker.
ALYSON LA: The
project that I did
using Tableau was called
Open Source Monthly.
And internally we
wanted to just take
a look at what was going
on in our organization
and the repository is within
the GitHub organization.
The public repository, that is.
So I was able to connect
Tableau directly with BigQuery
and pull in the
events data and start
to do some analysis
looking at what
are the most active repositories
within the whole org, who
are the most active
contributors, contributing
to the org.
And what is the most
common event type.
Whether that's an issue being
created or a star or a fork.
And just kind of
get the overall view
of what's going on within the
organization in open source.
FELIPE HOFFA: You're publishing
this with Tableau public now.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, that's right.
So this is all public.
So taking a look at the
GitHub organization,
so this is connected
on a monthly basis.
So November 2015 is
when I did this project.
It's showing that
the most common event
type is star for our org.
HUBOT, our robot, is the
most active contributor.
And then we can scroll it
down. [INTERPOSING VOICES]
And then this is a, they call
them tree maps or tree graphs.
The rectangle equals the size
of the amount of events going on
in that repository.
Our gitignore repository is
super active as far as events.
And then Git LFS and then
our git HUBOT for this month.
FELIPE HOFFA: How do with
these reports with Tableau?
ALYSON LA: So I create it
using the Tableau workbook,
which I have on my desktop.
And I can do a direct
connect to Google BigQuery.
I just have to click
Google BigQuery
and enter my credentials.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
keep your password safe.
ALYSON LA: And sign in,
and then allow access.
And then so once I've
connected my Tableau workbook
with BigQuery, I will
be able to see that it's
connected the server here.
And I can select a
project here or the public
dataset we can at.
But to access the GitHub Archive
I just type in GitHub Archive.
FELIPE HOFFA: The
name of the project
that contains the dataset.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
And then scroll down and look at
the dataset that I want to use.
So I want to use the month.
And I can scroll down to get
the most recent complete month,
which would be September here.
And I can drag that
over and update.
And this is like doing, you
know, select star limit 10,
where I can see the
output of the table.
And just kind of overview
what's in the table contents.
And then from here, I
can go to the worksheet
and start dragging and dropping
to do some exploratory analysis
using Tableau.
FELIPE HOFFA: Si Tableau
understands all of the columns
you have here and--
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
It already knows the dates
should be in a date format,
booleans are true,
false, numbers, strings.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
for example, if you
want to know the
most frequent event.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
So I could just select
type and number of records
and do show me bar chart.
And just to get an overview, I
can see, if I filter this down,
that push events are
the most common events
for this month, followed
by create events, watch
events and issue comments.
FELIPE HOFFA: And if you want to
filter these events by any way.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so you
can slice and dice it
a couple of different ways.
You can drag the org
log in here to Filter.
And from there it will
allow you to choose,
say I can choose
Google as the name
of the organization on GitHub.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
those are projects
hosted under the
Google organization.
GitHub organization.
ALYSON LA: That's correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now we
can see how people are
interacting with this project.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, exactly.
So these are the different
events triggered,
filtered specifically on the
log-in for Google organization.
You can see it's a
different shape here.
Before it was mostly push
events and the most common event
type for the Google
organization was a watch event,
which is considered starring.
FELIPE HOFFA: How
many stars did we get?
ALYSON LA: 15,000.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And here you can
keep drilling in.
You can look at the
most popular projects,
what people are doing.
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: But you are
using not only Tableau here.
ALYSON LA: That's right.
So recently I got
started using Looker,
which is also an analysis
tool similar to Tableau.
But the nice thing
about Looker is
it allows you to do a data
connection to BigQuery.
But then build a
model layer, where
it allows you to
basically do pre-joins,
if you want to do it.
You can do the JSON extract
directly in the model layer.
And we love it because
it's all version-controlled
using can GitHub.
So taking a look, here
is an example dashboard
using the GitHub web
archive latest events.
So again, using a
short date range.
This is filtered to
just the last two days.
This is an example
of the dashboard
that you can use
to see the number
of active users, the number
of active organizations,
repositories.
You know, the event types,
developers by commit counts.
And again, most popular
languages here by pull request
account.
And then you can filter it
to any organization you want.
So say, we can look at Angular
here, and see on the dashboard
that in this time
period of two days
there were 530 active users.
Anyone that interacted with
any repositories on Angular
organization, 65
active repositories.
And then you can see that
the most popular languages
by pull request are a
little bit different.
JavaScript, TypeScript,
HTML and Java.
FELIPE HOFFA: And the
interesting thing about Looker
is it adds a layer where Looker
understands what the underlying
data is.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, I can
show you that model layer.
FELIPE HOFFA: So it's a model
that someone has to write?
ALYSON LA: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: But only one
person at the organization
needs to understand.
ALYSON LA: I think
helps for other people
to understand the model
and how it's built.
But not everyone needs to know
how to write the model layer.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this
is GitHub's model.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so
this is the model
for all of the public events.
And Looker's really
neat because it
has this ID where
it tells you what
you have not committed yet.
So these green lines are things
that I still need to push up.
FELIPE HOFFA: Using GitHub?
ALYSON LA: Using GitHub, yeah.
And I can just
press commit changes
and it will push it
up to the hosted Git
Repository on GitHub.
But for example, this
pull request action here,
I can do this JSON extract here.
And then I can
filter on the action.
So when I go to do the
analysis, I can just
pick action equals
opened or closed
and it allows me to
pick out the pre-filter
and do the JSON extract here.
FELIPE HOFFA: So anyone
that's working with Looker
doesn't need to understand
that if some data is
[INAUDIBLE] JSON.
The model takes care of
extracting that away.
ALYSON LA: Yeah
FELIPE HOFFA:
That's really cool.
What a lot of
people ask me is how
to translate these interesting
metrics into actionable advice.
Like what kind of things can you
do that translate into action?
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so something
we're thinking about
internally is open source KPIs,
or Key Performance Indicators
using the BigQuery datasets.
So things like open source
monthly active users
or monthly active repositories,
and tracking that over time.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we can
look at people by region,
how they are
interacting with GitHub.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, so another
way to measure user engagement
is looking at monthly active
users and daily active users,
and seeing the ratio by region
to see where some users are
less engaged than others.
And just really by region
how different regions
are using GitHub differently.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this is
really, really awesome.
I love how anyone
at home can start
writing their own queries,
finding this status
of other public datasets.
Any advice for someone that
wants to start on this path?
ALYSON LA: Yeah.
So my advice would be to check
out the published queries.
You have some out floating
around the Internet.
There are some in the gist
that I linked in the Octoverse.
FELIPE HOFFA: We're putting
all of those links here.
ALYSON LA: Yeah, check
out the links below.
And then also check
out the developer docs
where you can learn
about the different event
types and the payload.
So you can understand exactly
what's going on there.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we have
everything documented.
We have sample queries.
We have sample analyses.
Now it's up to you to
start working with this.
And as for you, please
start trying out BigQuery.
Find open datasets.
Remember that you have a
monthly terabyte of no cost
to run your own queries.
Check all of the resources we
left on this video description.
And I'm out for today.
Thank you very much
and stay curious.
Thank you, Alyson.
ALYSON LA: Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: Woo!